Today, uh, is novel Pitch Day.
Uh, does everyone have a ballot?
If you don't have a ballot there,
some down here
we have a wonderful list of six novels
all brought to you by students from this
class.
I'll tell you,
my dream is that one day someone
will pitch their own novel.
That's my dream. And I yell,
this could happen. Yes.
Thank you.
[inaudible] okay,
we ready?
Yup.
Ballot [inaudible] without [inaudible]
further ado, if everybody
is ready, everybody ready?
Now,
each of these students has been
given five minutes only to make their
presentation. And uh, at the end of it,
you will rank your top three choices.
One for your first choice,
two for your second choice. Three,
the tfs will take your ballots,
they will leave the room.
I will begin to lecture on housekeeping.
And when they've added it all up,
which should go pretty fast because
there are nine of them and they,
they're very good at adding.
Um,
you have to know that to get
into the PHD programs here, uh,
there's a little arithmetic test.
Um,
they will add it all up and then I will
announce at the end of end of the class
which book it will be. So,
uh, without further ado,
Emma bearish will come and talk.
Trust [inaudible] to use this training.
Yes, you can. Oh yes. Use this microphone
please. So that the camera can hear you.
Okay.
Hi Camera.
Uh,
well thank you professor.
Hunger for diamond a bearish and I'm
pitching Giovanni's room by James Baldwin.
Uh, so what is Baldwin like? Well,
Baldwin is one of the Great 20th Century
American Authors and he has some really
unique insights into human interaction
and a shrewd sensitivity and to the
internal lives of his characters.
Um,
his background kind of shines through
his prose. He's the son of a preacher,
so his words have this like really
strong sort of grandness to them.
And there's a really, really a unique
resonance to everything he writes.
Anyway,
show Baldwin in my opinion,
isn't read as often as she as often,
excuse me,
as he should and academic settings.
So whew.
So I chose this book because I wanted to
use this opportunity to read Baldwin at
Yale. And nifty little
fact about Giovanni's room.
It's about 150 pages and yeah.
Yeah. And it's eminently readable.
So that's a, that's a big plus
at the end of the semester.
But also I didn't just choose
Giovanni's room because it's short.
I chose it because it fits
seamlessly with our syllabus.
So what's Giovanni's room about?
Well,
Giovanni's room is the story of David
a 20 something man who flees America to
Paris in hopes of finding himself. Milan,
Paris, David Fine's, a fiance, hello.
And in her absence, another
lover, Giovanni on man.
So the novel spirals around David's
reverie on one particular evening,
the evening of Giovanni's execution.
I don't want to ruin anymore of the book,
so I'll let you wonder what
offense Giovanni has committed.
Now Giovanni's room fits with
the notion of the identity plot,
which professor Hungerford was
discussing a lot last week.
But here the identity problem
is founded in sexuality.
A fascinating issue, which the literature
we've studied so far has yet to,
to explore. Uh, so Giovanni's room
complicates the identity plot further,
but you have on these were Giovanni's
room also explores national identity.
It is an American novel of x
patriotism, an American in Paris. Um,
so without further ado,
I want to read a passage in which David
realizes his alienation from America and
from Americanists.
So here he is walking into the American
post office in Paris to pick up his
mail,
yet walking into the American Express
office when harshly bright mid summer
afternoon,
I was forced to admit that this active
so disquietingly cheerful hordes struck
the eye at once as a unit at home,
I could have distinguished patterns,
habits, accents of speech
with no effort, whatever.
Now everybody sounded,
unless I listened hard as though he
had just arrived from Nebraska at home,
I could have seen the clothes they
were wearing. But here I only saw bags,
camera's belts, and hats all clearly
from the same department store at home.
I would've had some sense
of the individual womanhood.
If the woman I faced here,
the most ferociously accomplished,
seem to be involved in some ice
cold or Sun dried travesty of sex.
And even grandmothers seemed to
have had no traffic with the flesh.
And what distinguished the men was
that they seemed incapable of age.
They smelled of soap,
which seemed indeed to be
their preservative against
the dangers and exigencies
of any more intimate odor.
The boy,
he had been shown somehow
unsoiled untouched,
unchanged through the eyes of the man
of 60 booking passage with his smiling
wife to Rome. His wife might've been
his mother forcing more ointment,
oatmeal down his throat and ruin might've
been the movie she had promised to
allow him to see. Yet I also
suspected that what I was seeing was,
but a part of the truth and perhaps not
even the most important part beneath
these faces,
these clothes accents,
rudeness is was power and sorrow
both admitted on realize the power of
inventors, the sorrow of
the disconnected. Okay.
All right. Here you see that
miserable sense of separation,
that confusion, that
hopelessness, that Baldwin crafts,
that loss of identity,
and perhaps you can begin to see the
beauty and the might of his language,
which molds such a powerful story of love,
of loss and most importantly
of self. Okay, thank you.
[inaudible] Kelsey,
where are you?
Are you ready for that? Just
a second. Hello, I'm Kelsey.
See and the book that I'm pitching is
one flew over the cuckoo's nest by Ken
Keasy.
Um,
it is about an a set in an insane asylum
and the narrator is a six foot seven
schizophrenia deaf mute Indian
chief named chief Brondon,
whose life is turned upside down by a
brutal and hedonistic man named Randall
McMurphy. And, um, Ken Qc, who I need
to talk about a little bit, well,
it's sort of a rock star.
He was to the hippie generation.
What Jack Kerouac was to the
beat generation. He was the,
as most pro outmost outspoken
proponent of LSD. Um,
he and his merry pranksters went on
the road and their magic bus, um,
touting it across the nation.
Um,
one road trip that he took in 1964 with
Neal Cassady the same Neal Cassady who
dean Moriarty was crafted
after, um, was, um,
written down in a book by Tom Wolf
called the electric koolaid acid trip.
So he has that sort of in common
with Jack Kerouac. And, um,
I'd like to play a little clip that I
have from a BBC interview with Casey about
Lsd effects on his writing.
Hmm.
Oh, just some background in front
of just some background information.
While he was writing one
flew over the cuckoo's nest.
He was working in a mental institution.
He should were your answers at the
hospital inspiring to write a novel?
One flew over the cuckoo's nest.
He claims the drugs and
it's just creativity.
I would've have not been able
to write that well without LSD.
[inaudible] because
right from rise to fame,
how did they ask every time
shortcut?
Should I lighten [inaudible] for those
of us who were like to go on the better
realities and
prescribed,
let's say, okay, the door's
been open this to the open. It
okay
for that cheesy opens the door that Qsi
opens in one flew over the cuckoo's nest
reveals the inner workings
of an insane asylum. Um,
this of course draws attention to
the one most obvious and also most
complicating theme of the
book. That of madness. Um,
we've touched on the theme of madness
before with Lolita and with, um,
Franny and Zooey,
but I don't think we've addressed it as
explicitly as we would with this book.
I'm,
the book is set in an insane asylum.
There is no way to avoid
insanity. Um, at first glance,
that might seem like a very
straight forward assertion. However,
the very sense of omnipresent madness and
the book is the one that I think ropes
this book very neatly into the argument
of Professor Hungerford Syllabus. Um,
I think it's an intensification of
most of the things we studied so far.
For example,
the identity plot.
I think it's a very unique manifestation
of the identity plot because the people
in the insane asylum are perhaps one of
the most isolated groups that you could
possibly be, be a part of their
isolated by their own neuroses,
the tyranny of the nurses and,
and barricade of concrete
plexiglass and barbed wire. Um,
I think if you imagine any attempt to
find yourself within the confines of a
sanatorium, you can sort of
see how interesting a story
would be crafted on that.
Um,
another theme that we've talked about
is the relationship between language and
experience.
We talked about that with John Barth
and I think that's really important
question to focus on when you're reading
a book like this because you have to
think to yourself as you're reading,
how does an author accurately
capture the experience of insanity?
And more importantly,
how can we as readers trust a narrator
that self diagnosed as insane? Um,
and in that same vein, what is truth
and how does one portrayed truth?
I like to read a passage from the book.
This is at the very beginning when we're
first introduced to the chief and he
decides that he is going to begin telling
about all this about the hospital and
her and the guys and about being Murphy.
I've been silent so long now it's going
to roar out of me like flood waters.
And you think the guy telling this
is ranting and raving, my God,
you think this is too horrible
to have really happened?
This is too awful to be the truth,
but please,
it's still hard for me to have a clear
mind thinking on it. But it's the truth,
even if it didn't happen.
So I think you can see to the confusion
that can arise from having an insane
narrator.
Um,
one of the most enticing aspects
of this book is that it is funny,
they're extremely hilarious
aspects of this book.
I don't know if any of you who've seen
the movie or at least that famous clip of
Jack Nicholson laughing like a maniac.
Um,
the movie in general doesn't do the book
justice at all whatsoever, of course.
But, um, I think that one moment is
quintessentially kit keasy and he used it.
Humor, humor is his most powerful
tool in conveying his deepest,
serious messages in this book.
Um,
one thing that I want to point out is
there's this really fascinating thing that
happens over the course of this book,
and it's this,
there's an x that frames the plot and
that x one arm is the chief's ascension
from insanity. And the other
arm is remaking McMurphy's
descension into insanity.
I think if we choose this book,
one of the most challenging aspects of
our analysis of it will be defined where
the two slopes of those
intersect. Um, just to wrap up,
I think that this book is absolutely
phenomenal and it's completely engrossing.
My own introduction to
it was completely random.
It was one of the books that my roommate
happened to throw into her suitcase
before she came to Yale. And I read
it at the beginning of the year.
I took it with me and my grandparents
over weekend and I didn't sleep the entire
weekend cause I was reading it. And,
um, I think if you choose this book,
each and every one of you will be equally
as enthralled. So I hope you pick it.
[inaudible]
hi,
I'm pitching a Joan Didion's
play it as it lays. Um,
Joan Didion is in my mind,
one of the greatest intellectuals of
the second half of the 20th century.
She is perhaps best
known for her journalism,
particularly her collection of essays,
slouching towards Bethlehem,
which I believe came out in 1968 in
which she Cooley confronts and sensibly
analyzes the confusing cultural
climate of the late 1960s.
What do you think is most
report remarkable about her
reporting is the lack of
naivete with which this literally tiny
woman. I don't know if any of you seen,
and I'm sure many of you seen,
I've seen a picture of her. She's,
she's just remarkably small
[inaudible] so she is,
she's clear eyed but not unsympathetic,
innocent but detached and above all
candidate in her assessment of her country
and her time.
Um,
the voice that she develops in slouching
towards Bethlehem serves her very well
and play it as it lays.
She's able here to,
to draw the same sort of precise
portraits that you relied upon in her
nonfiction. There's lots of the novel
that is positively, undeniably seductive.
The plot revolves around a sort
of marginal actress Mariah Yf,
who's divorced from our director,
husband,
and who drifts aimlessly through the
Hollywood party scene of the late 1960s
waiting for something to touch her,
impact her emotionally and morally.
She's both damaged and as a result,
utterly unreachable tragedies.
And there are many major and minor
that sort of float blithely by slip,
slip off her or appear to.
It was a novel,
very much about a woman who
accepts everything, feels nothing,
and finally resigned herself
to the inevitable. The
inevitable is in many cases,
trivial fates dealt out
at cocktail parties.
It is told in several voices Mariah's
and three of her closest friends.
And each character is haunted by an
ineffable loss of meaning and consequences
that they either ignore or are ignorant
of willfully or otherwise. In many ways,
these lives,
these characters lives are,
are coming or drifting apart and their
lack of awareness of this fact becomes
through Didion's, uh, pros our own.
So that's the shock of the final scenes
is both powerful and hopelessly hollow.
And I don't mean that in a negative sense.
I mean that we feel that consequences
perhaps or are unimportant,
that there's, there's something larger
at work. Um, so play it as it lays,
I think fits very nicely into the
syllabus because it provides a beautiful
contrast to the crying of lot 49 and
that it depicts the disintegration of
southern California and specifically
La and a much less manic but no trial,
no less troubling way Didion's language
and it's flat plain tone minimums mimics
the flat plain Los Angeles of her
narrative as pensions convoluted,
elusive language does his perplexing and
intricate portrait of the city. Also,
as with housekeeping, the loss of self
is imagined as a dispersal though.
When did he in this dispersal is a cold,
defensive and ultimately
empty one slouching towards
Bethlehem because the quote
from Yates that includes the phrase,
the center will not hold.
This is become very emblematic
of that era. Mariah,
who in the first few pages declares that
nothing applies to her is perhaps one
of the most poignant examples of the
personal consequences of the loosening,
the loss of cultural restrictions
in the 1960s a time when in fact,
none of the old rules applied
to her or anyone else did.
Ian Proposes that the consequences of
this freedom might be more than any single
individual can cope with. Um,
that in fact, if nothing applies,
the individual center, no
lessons. Societies cannot hold it.
His account of the 60s that
appears perhaps elsewhere,
but was I think divine defined
by Didion. Um, in this novel. Uh,
and I want to read a very brief
paths from the beginning. Um,
uh,
here we go.
I am what I am to look for
reasons is beside the point,
but because the pursuit of reasons
is their business. Here she is,
I believe at this point institutionalized.
Uh, they asked me questions. Mariah,
yes or no. I see a cock in this
ink blot. Mariah, yes or no.
A large number of people are
guilty of bad sexual conduct.
I believe my sins are on pardonable.
I have been disappointed in love.
How could I answer? How could
it apply? Nothing applies.
I print with the magnet, magnetized
Ibm Pencil, what does apply?
They ask later as if the
word nothing were ambiguous,
open to interpretation of
questionable fragment of an,
of an Icelandic room.
There are only certain facts I say try
and again to be an agreeable player of
the game. Certain facts,
certain things that happened,
they will misread the facts,
invent connections, we'll
extrapolate reasons where none exist.
But I told you that is their business
here and I think it would be,
I think it would be wonderful to end
the semester with a strong female voice
that historically amusing,
courageous and especially cold.
And I don't mean cold in
the in the negative sense,
just that she approaches things in a
sort of detached way that allows you to
observe these characters but not attach
yourselves to them in a way that,
uh, the promotes is sort
of self identification, uh,
that makes it difficult for
you to judge their actions. Um,
perhaps most important. It's also
fairly short, just over 200 pages fast,
captivating read. Um, this
is sort of stupid analogy,
but I imagine it's sort of like getting
on a highway in La, not during rush hour,
but sort of a heading. Which way are
you going? Maybe east towards the hills.
Um,
and
you get to your exit sort of before
you realize it. Um, so that's my pitch.
Thank you.
[inaudible]
hi,
my name is will,
I'm pitching Jesus's son by Denis
Johnson. Um, I'm actually gonna start,
but without introducing it at all.
I'm just going to play a clip from the
movie that was made of the book and then
I'm going to talk about
that was a clip from the movie version
of Jesus son. Um, and this is the book,
it's by Dennis Johnson, who has been in
the news a lot lately because he wrote,
um, tree of smoke, which won the
national book award in 2007. Um,
and this, this book is kind of the book
that established him as like a serious,
great author. Um, and I,
I think it's wonderful.
It's a collection of stories.
Um,
and they're all kind of
about the same character. Um,
one of the characters
you saw in there and uh,
the kind of the same group of characters
runs through all the different stories.
Um, and so it's kind of
novelistic in that way.
Kind of like I'm lost in the
fun house, the book we read. Um,
I guess, uh, the,
as you might or might not have been able
to tell from the clip the book kind of
deals with a drug addiction and the main
character is addicted to heroin. Um,
but I really think the book kind
of transcends that drug genre. Um,
I really, uh, don't, I'm not a
huge fan of drug books myself,
but I think this,
but I think this book is really,
really beautiful and powerful and
devastating and really hilarious,
really funny at times. Um, I
guess what else? It's short, uh,
like everyone else has been saying,
but this book really is short. Uh,
[inaudible]
it's a, it's only 160 pages and there
really aren't very many words then.
Um, cause it's quite, it's
quite small as you can see. Um,
uh, and, and I really, I find this book,
um, I mean, I don't know how much I
want to describe it, but it's the main,
it takes place mostly in Iowa and kind
of just travels around kind of like daily
things. That one, one of
the stories, they, uh,
the main character and his friend decided
to rip scrap metal from a house and
sell it, uh, to make a little money
so they can get drunk that night. Um,
and just different kinds of adventures
that they get. One and it's really, um,
and then, uh, the book
kind of ends in a mercy,
makes us kind of pilgrimage to
Arizona. Um, it's really beautiful.
I guess I'll just read
you a quick passage.
That's all right.
Um,
we bumped softly down a hill toward an
open field that seemed to be a military
graveyard filled with rows and rows of
austere identical markers over soldiers.
I'd never before come across the cemetery
on the farther side of the field,
just beyond the curtains of snow.
The Sky was torn away and the angels
were descending out of a brilliant blue
summer. They're huge faces streaked
with light and full of pity.
The sight of them cut through my heart
and down the knuckles of my spine and if
there been anything in my bowels,
I would have messed my pants from fear.
Georgie opened his arms and cried out.
It's the drive and man the drive in.
I wasn't sure what these words meant.
They're showing movies in a fucking
blizzard. George screamed. I see.
I thought it was something else.
I said.
We walked carefully down there and climbed
through the busted fence and stood in
the very back. The speakers, which
I had mistaken for grave markers,
muttered in unison. Then there was tinkly
music of which I could barely knew,
very nearly make out the tune.
Famous movie stars Rode Bicycles beside
a river laughing out of their gigantic,
lovely mouth's.
If anybody had ever come to see this show,
they'd have left when the weather started.
Not One car remains not even a broken
down one from last week or one left here
because it was out of gas and a couple
of minutes in the middle of a whirling
square dance. The screen turn
black, the cinematic summer ended,
the snow went dark. There was
nothing but my breath. Um,
so I guess that gives you enough of
an idea of it. Um, I think it's great.
I think you should vote for it.
It's quick reads,
really riveting and enthralling and uh,
I find it really incredible book.
So Jesus son
[inaudible].
Hi, I'm Eli. Um, uh,
the book I wanted to pitch was everything
is illuminated by Jonathan Safran for
um,
and uh,
the main reason I want to pitch it of
course was professor Hungerford said that
she's waiting for one of us to
pitch a their own book. And, um,
contrary to conventional wisdom.
This is actually my own book you see now,
but setting side authorship issues.
The other thing is you just had to
introduce the seed of doubt and then the
rumors percolate. So this is, um, I, uh,
I love books that had outrageous
characters actually hearing some of these
pitches. I was like, Oh, maybe I
should vote for some other boats,
but I want to tell you
that. But, um, this book,
but this book does have
outrageous characters, which
is really cool. Um, and, uh,
also I just thought the pitch,
I would just kind of describe some
of the characters and you'd be like,
those characters are indeed outrageous.
There you go. I will vote for this book.
So the book kind of takes
place in two different worlds.
One is the world of track and broad,
um,
which is a small shtetl
in the 18th century. Um,
and also Jonathan Safran for his ancestral
home and the other world is kind of
modern day Ukraine. Um, and it, it,
it features Jonathan Safran
Foer on a quest as I'm,
I don't know if you Jews out there,
I'm sure at some point I had
done this as I have, you know,
been drawn to like Slovakia,
Ukraine to find the ancestral home.
And that's what Jonathan said before
is doing this book. So I'm in the, uh,
kind of modern day world. Um, there
are a number of really cool characters.
The main one is the hero,
Jonathan Safran for who is also referred
to as the quote spoiled you and the
quote. And Genius to, um, the, uh,
other characters is humble
translator Alexander Shove,
who learned English exclusively through
the use of a thesaurus. Um, and who, uh,
which produces some outrageous results
and who works for the family business
heritage touring, which is he,
his description of it is a quote.
It's for Jewish people like the hero who
have cravings to leave the unknowable
country America and visit humble
towns in Poland and Ukraine.
I will be truthful again and
mentioned that before this voyage,
I have the opinion that Jewish people
were having shit between their brains.
That is because all I knew of Jewish
people was that they paid father very much
currency in order to make vacations
from America to Ukraine if we forgot.
And then there's also a Alex's
dog, Sammy Davis, Jr Jr,
which is, um, heritage Turing's
coat officious seeing I bitch.
Um, so, and that's one road. And then in
the other world, the world of the Shtetl,
we have a well regarded rabbi who
speaks exclusively in capitals.
We have a broad,
a brilliant girl,
and a magic emerges magically from a
river has adopted by the disgrace user.
Yankel Yankel d we have two synagogues,
the congregation of the slouchers
and the congregation of the upright.
We have villagers including the deceased
philosopher pin class t who in his only
notable paper to the dust from man you
came. And two man, you shall return,
argues that it would be possible in
theory for life in art to be reversed.
We have the good gefilte fish
monger bits, little bits. We'll are,
we have the mad squire and village
rapists. Sophia out. Can we have Harry v,
the [inaudible] master logician and
resident pervert who had been working for
many years on his magnum opus,
the host of hoists,
which he promised contain the tightest
of tight logical proofs that God
indiscriminately loves the
indiscriminant lover. Um,
I don't know how many of us that
will pardon here, but anyhow,
so besides these outrageous characters,
I do think that the book fits well
with the themes of the course. Um,
it deals with identity, um,
language and experience,
problems of narration and remembrance.
Um, as a, the New York Times Book Review,
I guess you can say lauded the book I'm
quoting, not since a clockwork orange,
has the English language
been simultaneously mauled
and energized with such
brilliance and such Breo.
Um, so going with that,
I thought I'd read as people have been
inclined to do a passage from the book,
I'm going to take a little risk here.
Um,
I've been reading the book with
a Russian accent in my head. Um,
so I figured I would just,
you know, I would be okay.
I figured that would have
the added benefit of like,
you're not gonna like be like, you
know, if you don't vote for this book,
then I'll just be the kid who made a
fool of himself and red with a Russian
accent in front of everybody.
So I know you don't want to do that to me
unless, yeah. Okay. So here we go.
This is Alex kind of introducing
himself at the beginning of the book.
I did Negroes,
particularly Michael Jackson,
I did to disseminate very much, couldn't
see at famous nightclubs in Odessa.
Lamborghini Countach is excellent.
And so our cappuccinos and many girls
want to be carnal with me and many good
arrangements,
not withstanding the inebriated kangaroo,
the Gorky tickle and the
unyielding zookeeper.
If you want to know why so
many girls want to be with me,
it is because I am very premium person.
There'll be with I am humbly and also
severely funny and these are winning
things.
But nonetheless,
I know many people with Diego rapid cars
and famous disco techs that are so many,
her pro who performed the Sputnik bosom
deleons which is always terminated with
slimy on their face that they cannot tell
you them on all my hands that are even
many people named Alex 30 in my house
alone. That is why I was so effervescent.
The goto lots and translate for Jonathan
Safran Foer it would be an ordinary.
So that is said in a full,
proudly made [inaudible]
well, uh, it's really unfortunate
to have to go after that.
But uh, hi, my name is Roger. I'm
presenting for Amenas section. Um,
and we're uh, doing Dave
Edgars. What is the,
what you can't see the one because
it's 20% off plug. Plug. Um, and, uh,
I guess rather than a trip to sound the
book myself, I'll use a, not the authors,
but the person about whom the book is
written, his own words. Uh, what is the,
what is the soulful account of my life
from the time I was separated from my
family in Mario by if I
mispronounced that I'm so sorry. Um,
to the 13 years I spent an
Ethiopian and Kenyan refugee camps.
Do you mind counter with vibrant western
cultures beginning in Atlanta to the
generosity and challenges that
I encountered elsewhere? Um,
so just add a little bit to that.
What is the,
what is it is a story of a Sudanese
refugee in the United States. Um,
and in the course of telling it,
he weeps and accounts from his life
back in Africa to stories. I'm here,
the United States and
everything in between. Um,
as for reasons why you should want
to vote for it or read it. Um,
I think the first thing, which
many of us in the section, um,
realize how the book is just
that it's really engaging.
It's written in a way
that's, um, I get like,
I would say kind of refreshing
compared to some of the other more, uh,
how to put it on complex, uh,
authors that we've read, um,
in that it's just really accessible and,
you know,
really just an easy read that that's,
that's, that's deeply human. I mean,
you feel like you're having a
conversation with the guy. Um,
and even though the guys actually
having a conversation with David Edgars,
so maybe that's why you get that
impression. But, um, at any rate, uh,
it's also a book which manages to,
um, address really, really serious,
um, can kind of, you know, current
issues such as civil war, uh, Chan aside,
um,
alienation in American society,
but do so in a way that simultaneously
really poignant and inspiring,
but also actually funny.
Like it's not a book that you're
going to read and be depressed by,
even though you will come from it.
Having really felt that you're, you're,
you're dealing with really
significant material, which, um,
I thought is really cool and
we thought was really cool. Um,
it's also just going on the
whole like contemporary thing.
It's written by one of the
best contemporary authors
out there. Uh, he's, uh,
he was nominated for a Pulitzer prize,
or here's a Pulitzer prize finalist,
I think last year in 2007. I'm not sure,
um, if I got that wrong and some of,
here's the big Eggers fan. I'm terribly
sorry. Um, but, uh, yeah, he's great.
And intercourse where we went, you know,
doing from 1945 to the present. Um,
I think it's good to have to have a
really strong, really contemporary author,
um, represented. So that's another cool
thing. Um, another thing which I think is,
which would be really cool I'm reading
this book, is that it's not an act,
it's not your standard
academic book at all. I mean,
you're not gonna find this book
on any syllabus, but I mean,
it's still really merits,
um, like being read in,
in that sort of context because of the,
you know,
the depth of the material is being
covered because of the way it's written.
It's really,
there's some beautiful descriptions.
There's beautiful language and Wealthfront
and for any other reason that you'd
want to read a book in the class, it can
serve that function. And yet, you know,
you'd probably be more like to hear about
it in a coffee shop or in a restaurant.
Um, so I mean, I think that's a,
that's a pretty cool opportunity,
which this would give us, um, as far
as like tying into the course matters.
This book is a great, great study
and I think, I would think, um, uh,
an unprecedented study as far as that
identity plot goes for our class because,
um, as a black African, I'm,
the protagonist is identified not by his
ethnicity in the United States, but by,
but by his race. Um, and as it's
shown in a, in a really very, uh,
you know, interesting, I guess
a scene in the, in the Vat,
the very meaning of the book where he's
being robbed by, by black man who, uh,
who says to him, Oh, well we're brothers
because your f on because you're African.
And at the same time to ride's only refers
to as African and actually mislabeled.
And as Nigerian when he's Sudanese.
Um,
so it really offers some
really interesting perspective
into issues of, of race,
issues of ethnicity, um, and just, uh,
just a totally new look at American
society, um, from, uh, yeah, uh,
perspective that we're not really
used to. Um, I guess, yeah,
that basically covers
that as far as some other,
maybe a little bit sillier things.
This is a great date book for those of
you who are either are dating or are
looking to be dating. If
the PR, I mean visits,
it's a book that people are
reading all of the time. Um,
and even if they aren't reading,
then you know,
you can really wow them with just your
knowledge of contemporary contemporary
literature and to say nothing of your
concern for the people who are struggling
in America and abroad. So I'm really
that, that's a big plug. And um,
it's also one of, it's
one, a bunch of awards.
It was a finalist for at least one of
finals towards a final finalist for the
national book critics Circle Award for
fiction, which I think is good. Um,
and the guy from Barnes and noble would
not let me leave the counter because he
liked it so much and he's a good judge.
So, um, those are some really good plugs.
But as far as weakness,
you might notice it's a little bit
bigger than some of the other books that
we've read. But I promise you that
that's okay if you fly through the pages.
And just to give you a
sense of why you do that.
I'll read 'em to you a
section from the book.
It's actually the last
paragraph of the book, but this,
it's not like one of those sports I like.
And then your mother died. No, it's um,
this is,
it actually really I think is very fitting
to read now because it's kind of his
plug for why you should read his book,
or at least it's a description of why
he tells his story. So here we go. Um,
whatever I do, however I find a way
to live, I will tell these stories.
I've spoken to every person I've
encountered these last difficult days.
And every person who is an entered this
club during these awful morning hours
because to do anything else would
be something less than human.
I speak to these people and I speak
to you because I cannot help it.
It gives me strength, almost unbelievable
strength to know that you are there.
I covet your eyes, your ears,
the collapsible space between us.
How blessed are we to have each other.
I'm alive and you are alive,
so we must fill the air with our
words. I will feel today, tomorrow,
everyday until I am taken back to God.
I will tell these stories to people who
will listen and to people who don't want
to listen to people who seek me out
and to those who run all the while,
I will know that you are there.
How can I pretend that you do not exist?
It would be almost as impossible as you
pretending that I do not exist. Thanks.
[inaudible].
Okay. Vote. If this were
really a high tech classroom,
we'd have a little console
for you and you'd be voting
online, but we don't. Okay,
so okay.
Anyone need a ballot?
Thank you.
Okay. Rank them. One, two, three.
Ta's get to vote to yes you do.
Okay.
And when you're finished, pass them to
the isles. Can I borrow your pencil?
Okay,
sure.
I'm voting to
[inaudible].
Okay.
Everybody voted
okay?
Tfs everybody done fasten fasten over.
Okay.
We will see them in a moment.
Well, let me say, uh, it, it's
a tough act to follow you guys.
So congratulations to all the
people who pitched books. Um,
although I have to say I'm a little
hurt at the implied criticism long,
long, hard, hard board.
I don't recognize my own syllabus.
Maybe the long,
but I'm not the heart of
the boring. Um, so, uh,
we will see what that next book will be.
Now I have exactly five minutes.
So,
um,
what do you think I want to do is just
say something very quick about um,
loss in this book.
I put this quote up on the board need
can blossom into all the compensation it
requires.
That little blurb I
think encapsulates this.
Novels,
meditation on loss.
I asked you last time to think
about where Ruth's voice comes from,
what situation we can imagine.
And there are bunch of different theories
that critics have put forward about
where Ruth is in from where
we hear her voice coming.
One is that she's dead and she's speaking
to us from the afterlife that she
really somehow did die in the lake that
day that she fell off the bridge or
somehow the bridge is a metaphor for her
passage into death or that this is an
adult Ruth living who knows where or
just as a transient who has written this
account or who speaks to us somehow.
I think that quotation from
Maryland Robinson that I
gave you at the end of last
lecture about how she aims to speak in
the voice of the consciousness of the
person,
not necessarily the words that they
would use if they were to write their own
account,
suggest that what she's getting at
doesn't require that kind of historical
explanation to account for it.
That she doesn't want us to have to think
of Ruth's speaking from a particular
place,
which is also a way to
say that Ruth is gone.
Somehow Ruth is absent from us.
And this relates to my point last time
about identity is imagined as voice Ruth,
the historical Ruth,
the character Ruth, uh,
Ruth that we could situate in any concrete
position in the world has vanished
from the frame of this novel.
What we're left with is her voice.
The logic here is that vanishing
makes the voice totally present,
that full human presence is
in the voice somehow inherent.
That's why there are all these meditations
on what would happen if various
people either did disappear
or didn't disappear.
So when Ruth meditates on what it
would be like for her to leave Sylvie,
she says,
I did not want to grow gigantic
and multiple to Sylvie.
Her senses that by leaving Sylvie,
her absence would become enormous and she
herself in a kind of negative presence
would become larger than she is.
And this is how Ruth feels about
her own mother's disappearance,
that when her mother disappeared,
what she got in return was
the compensation of memory.
Sharp, specific, evocative,
mysterious ever present memory.
And the visual metaphor for this
kind of memory is of course the lake.
The lake is imagined to
contain hole and under Cade,
all the objects of the past
that have been lost in it.
So memories imagined in the same terms
so that you could always bring them up to
the surface and there they would be whole.
So the resurrection imagined if you run
the film backward of the train slipping
into the lake,
I read that passage last time.
The kind of resurrection
imagined is the way memory works.
But more specifically,
it's the way the language of memory works.
And I want to read, um, my
own, uh, favorite passage.
Uh,
this is at the very end of the novel.
And I want you to think as I read it
about the difference between this passage
and the one I read from
bluest eye about Pichola,
that passage of negativity about her being
a kind of blank or a negative against
which all other virtues could
be present in the world.
So think about that as I read this
bottom of two 17 since we are dead,
the house would be hers now hers Lucile,
perhaps she's in the kitchen snuggling
pretty daughters in her lap and perhaps
now and then they look at the black window
to find out what their mothers seems
to see there and they see
their own faces and a face.
So like their mothers so wrapped and
full of tender watching that only Lucile
could think of the face was mine.
If Lucille is there,
Sylvia and I have stood outside her
window a thousand times and we have thrown
the side door open when she was upstairs
changing beds and we have brought in
leaves and flung the curtains and tip
the bud vase and somehow left the house
again before she could run downstairs
leaving behind us a strong smell of lake
water. She would sign and
think they never change.
Or Imagine Lucille in Boston at a table
in a restaurant waiting for a friend.
She is tastefully dressed wearing say
a tweed suit with an amber scarf at the
throat to draw attention to
the red in her darkening hair.
Her water glass has left two thirds of
a ring on the table and she works at
completing the circle with her thumbnail.
Sylvie and I do not flounce in through
the door smoothing the skirts of are
oversized coats and combing
our hair back with our fingers.
We do not sit down at the table next to
hers and empty our pockets in a small
damp peep in the middle of the table
and sort out the gum wrappers and ticket
stubs and add up the coins and dollar
bills and laugh and add them again.
My mother likewise is not there.
And my grandmother in her house slippers
with her pig tail wagging and my
grandfather with his hair
combed flat against his brow,
does not examine the menu
with studious interest.
We are nowhere in Boston,
however,
Lucille may look,
she will never find us
there or any trace or sign.
We pause nowhere in Boston even to admire
a store window and the perimeters of
our wandering are nowhere.
No one watching this woman smear her
initials in the steam on her water glass
with her first finger or slip cellophane
packets of oyster crackers into her
handbag for the seagulls could know how
her thoughts are thronged by our absence
or know how she does not watch,
does not listen,
does not wait,
does not hope.
And always for me and Sylvie.
So you see in that incredibly
lyrical evo cation of absence,
how the very absence calls
forth this lyric voice,
the structure is exactly the same as the
one that Morrison uses to describe what
Pichola is to Claudia and Frieda
and the rest of their community.
It's a way in which absence calls forth
the living essence of other people.
But here what's called forth is a
sort of living essence of imagination,
a living essence of voice.
So that Sylvie and Ruth's absence for
Lucille becomes the very presence that
they have to her.
There's a passage earlier
in the novel where
she describes
the condition of the body that matches
up with this understanding of absence.
She's outside in the orchard.
This is on two oh three,
imagining, uh, the hair,
the story of a young girl in a
lighted house that she sees her.
Ha, uh, let's see. It would be that
kind of story of very melancholy story.
Her hair,
which was as black as the sky and so long
that it swept after her a wind in the
grass,
her fingers,
which were sky black and so fine and
slender that they were only cold touch,
like drops of rain.
Her step,
which was so silent that
people were surprised when
they even thought they heard
it.
She would be transformed by the gross
light into a mortal child and when she
stood at the bright window,
she would find that the world was gone.
The orchard was gone. Her mother
and grandmother and aunts were gone.
Like Noah's wife on the
10th or 15th night of rain,
she would stand in the window and realize
that the world was really lost and
those outside would scarcely know her.
So sadly was she changed before she
had been flashed in air and clothed in
nakedness and mantled in Cla in cold and
her very bones were only slender things
like shafts of ice. She had haunted
the orchard out of preference,
but she could walk into the lake without
ripple or displacement and sail up the
air invisibly as heat
and now lost to her kind.
She would almost forget them and she
would feed course food to her course flesh
and be almost satisfied.
And then Ruth meditates
on her transformation in
that time in the orchard.
If I had stayed there, I might have
discovered other things. For example,
I was hungry enough to begin to learn
that hunger has its pleasures and I was
happily at ease in the dark and in general
I could feel that I was breaking the
tethers of need. One one, what I would,
I would call this an anorexic aesthetic.
It's an aesthetic of starving the self
into invisibility so that the voice can
become present.
So in this scene,
when she imagines the girl inside
the house eating all that outside,
the houses lost,
all she can see when she looks out
her window is her own reflection.
But outside the house
she is starved into a kind of ethereal,
full presence.
So the logic of absence,
to bring it back round to this question
of identity and the identity of the
voice,
the logic of absence starves away the
person so that this fullness can appear,
and I think this is the dark side of a
novel that so many people initially read
as a feminist novel,
a novel celebrating the strength
and the independence of women.
It turns to an aesthetic that has
a kind of purchase in our culture.
That sense of anorexia blends into the
spiritual fullness of imagining memory as
this beautiful,
lyrical presence.
I think this is the complexity of
this novel. This is the tension.
It's also in many ways it's beauty.
So now I believe we have an answer.
Jonathan Safran Foer that
will be our novel. Eli,
congratulations.
[inaudible].
Thank you very much.
Have a wonderful break.